coming up on 6 25 on your memorial day
monday we're talking about the teeny
tiny traffic tie up that's just the
beginning of ndot's ginormous tropicana
transformation
the nevada department of
transportation's 305 million dollar
project at i-15 it's been broken up into
four phases but each of them is going to
get a lot more attention as they impact
all aspects of traffic in the area you
might miss the project's soft opening
it's starting tomorrow but it's only
small stretches of frank sinatra and
dean martin drives scheduled to have
lane shifts for a week for southbound
frank sinatra from trop to reno it is a
24 7 week-long move for dean martin
there will be nighttime work only
northbound from just north of hacienda
at alibaba
so not a lot going on right now but
we're all going to experience the huge
changes at the 15 and drop and whether
we know about them ahead of time or not
ndot is going out of its way to be as up
front as they can be a ton more stories
ahead we've got a link to ndot's project
website and the online version of this
story at 8newsnow.com click traffic then
driving you crazy buckle up drive
carefully put down that phone so i'm
driving you crazy email me traffic 8
8newsnow.com